uh this is one of those stories
that is only shocking if you're not
paying attention
donald trump reportedly said jews
here we go now jews are only
in it for themselves after a recent call
with jewish leaders
according to a new report is anybody
really shocked by this and i know people
will often come back and say
but trump's son-in-law is jewish trump
can't be anti-semitic oh but trump's
daughter converted to judaism oh but
trump's grandkids are jewish oh but
trump
moved the embassy from tel aviv to
jerusalem i even got a call about this
actually on on voicemail earlier this
week which i
played for you this is why all of that
stuff is
is meaningless by every reasonable
estimation
donald trump has the same tired old
stereotypical views about jewish folks
about black folks about hispanic folks
it's all the same stuff so
you know yes jews are only
in it for themselves this is what trump
reportedly said in front of officials
according to a new report from the
washington post more than two dozen
current
and former administration officials told
the washington post about trump's
private views on race
and described racist remarks that he has
made while in office
it's a widely sourced story more than 20
people talking about what they observed
the washington post writes that the
president's characterization of jews
happened after he got off the phone with
jewish
lawmakers during a conference call last
week with american jews
trump reportedly said we love your
country
referring to israel as if israel is the
country of american jews which is
another trope
he also told an audience of jewish
americans that israeli leader benjamin
netanyahu
is your prime minister which is wild
trump has previously called jews who are
democrats
disloyal and these are all common
anti-semitic tropes that have been
around
for a long time the idea that american
jews hold some greater allegiance to
israel
or a dual loyalty many of these are
folks who have never even been to israel
that
uh they are more loyal to israel than
their actual countries of
birth or of residence and at this point
the surprising thing is not that trump
is accused of saying this stuff
the surprising thing is that anybody's
shocked by it now
let's let's uh dig in a little more into
one aspect of this
this idea this trope of jews are in it
for themselves
most people are generally speaking
concerned with their own well-being look
at republicans right now with the
supreme court
are they in this for anybody but
themselves and their own
the the preservation of their ideology
this is the absurdity
of some of these tropes that are stuck
to one group
oh you know the trope of the jews love
money they're in it for the money
do do white people hate money do white
people not care about money
black people don't care about money
seeks they're against money
women hate money middle-aged people hate
money
that's part of the absurdity of some of
these tropes that
some of them are so vague and
meaningless
that it actually boggles the mind how
people can
seriously consider them assessments of a
particular group it's absurd
and trump of course is able to so
casually go
from one racist or xenophobic trope to
the next
almost second nature to him it it really
seems to come very naturally to him
now do i tell you this because i think
it's going to you know alter the
election results
no the people that are supporting trump
at this point
are not going to be dissuaded because
trump said uh jews are only in it for
themselves
the people who are already voting for
trump at this late stage in the game
are not going to be dissuaded because of
trump's racially tinged message that joe
biden
will destroy the suburbs by looking at
how housing policy can have
racial repercussions uh these people are
with trump no matter what the reason i i
tell you about this
uh is to just remind you that very often
we just have to believe what's plain as
day if it looks like a duck
if it sounds like a duck if it walks
like a duck
mostly it's a duck that's really the
concept of occam's razor
from the scientific world and that is
exactly what we are seeing here with
donald trump no surprise whatsoever
he is exactly what he appears to be uh
we have a fantastic program for you
today we are going to talk about
what is the risk to roe v wade if indeed
donald trump replaces ruth bader
ginsburg
with a handmaid's tale like ideologue
from the american right we are also
going to talk about
i mentioned undecided voters and decided
voters
who are the undecided voters right now
we have actually have some data about
them and we're going to talk about that
a little bit later
uh we're going to take some of your
phone calls and we have so much going on
next week not only do we have a week of
shows and a week of bonus shows if you
are a member which you should be
at joinedpakman.com we have the first
presidential debate biden vs trump
tuesday night join me on your choice
youtube twitch or facebook whichever you
like best
join me at 8 30 pm eastern 5 30 p.m
pacific for the first
biden vs trump debate it's going to be
wild
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video
chat this is not a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary
care and it's also so much more
affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me
with a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video